my name is well as far as I can remember
I've always dreamt of having an afro no
one had ever thought of putting
afros together with civil rights and
sound and the police got so poppin that
even white folks would come here to get
their hair done
that's Marvin he the barber from across
the street and the guys he sitting with
are his brothers happy the big is and
kinda anaconda don't ask the Vixen with
the multicolored nails that scary
Marvin's girlfriend the Portrait Gallery
wouldn't be completed but didn't tell
you about Nolan but a brother is a bit
jealous so let's try to keep that affect
comprehension you see my book I saw
hanging with one of the few delivery
boys again which one looks good
well good morning people I said look
like you and you can find a D&E grab me
my hair yes sir put me in my dorm
commander comes out she sees me she's
convinced they might kick by some
jealous husband whose wife I'm sayin hit
my kid back technically I want you to
find him right now
no you have us do that again please
what they have I didn't I think was the
one I didn't want to I will use you this
is not part of the plan
[Music]
shut up
[Music]
you